Das passiert 2.024
und das letzte wird schon Lange erwartet.
USB C wird im Dezember nächsten Jahre Pflicht.
Alle neuen Smartphones, Tablets,
Kameras und Kopfhörer
müssen dann einen USB C Anschluss haben.
2.024 finden die Präsidentschaftswahlen in den USA
statt. OB es wieder zum Duell beiden gegen Trump kommt,
wird man sehen.
Gute Nachrichten für alle Fußballfans,
denn die Fußball Europameisterschaft findet
in Deutschland statt.
Besorgt euch also jetzt schon Karten.
Vorher
gibt es jedoch auch die Handball Europameisterschaft
auch in Deutschland
und wir bleiben beim Sport.
Schnappt euch euren Crush,
denn 2.024
finden die Olympischen Spiele und Paralympics in Paris
statt Arztpraxen sind AB 01.2024 verpflichtet,
für verschreibungspflichtige Medikamente 1 E
Rezept auszustellen.
2.024 wird es aber auch sehr dunkel,
zumindest in Mittel und Nordamerika,
denn dort kommt es zu einer totalen Sonnenfinsternis.
Und zum Schluss noch eine wichtige Nachricht für viele,
Cannabis soll im 04.2014 nun endlich
zumindest in teilen legalisiert werden.
Und freust du dich auf die Änderung, denn.